hola de nuevo qué tal te van ahora
estamos en el problema número 10 que
está en la página 489 y bueno este
problema dice así esteban noto que es el
decimosegundo alumno más alto y el
décimo segundo alumno más bajo del salón
si cada uno de los estudiantes tiene una
altura distinta a los demás cuántos
alumnos hay en esa clase y bueno justo
este es de los problemas donde están
jugando a que te confundas y cuentes mal
y entonces te equivoques es de los
típicos problemas donde podemos contar
mal de la cantidad de alumnos y ahí
encontrarnos con el error fíjate bien si
yo acomoda a los alumnos del más bajo
del más bajo al más alto al más alto
entonces
esteban cumplen que es el décimo segundo
más alto déjame escribirlo aquí el
décimo segundo
y alto ya su vez el décimo segundo más
bajo del salón así que si este es
esteban déjame dibujarlo por aquí lo voy
a dibujar con sus dos ojos su cara feliz
y además le voy a dibujar una gorra si
éste es esteban entonces cuántos hay
antes que el más bajos y cuántos hay
después de él más altos de tal manera
que él quede en el lugar décimo segundo
en los más bajos y en el lugar décimo
segundo en los más altos y pensemos en
esteban si él fuera el segundo más bajo
del salón eso quiere decir que debería
de haber un niño con menor estatura que
esteban si fuera el tercero más bajo del
salón eso quiere decir que en este salón
debería de haber dos niños con menor
estatura que esteban si él fuera el
cuarto más bajo del salón deberían haber
tres niños que tuvieran menos estatura
que esteban por lo tanto si él es el
decimosegundo más bajo del salón aquí
debe de haber once niños que tengan
menor estatura que esteban
a niños niños con menor estatura que
esteban y de igual manera si pensamos en
lo alto si esteban es el segundo más
alto debe haber alguien más alto que él
si esteban es el tercero más alto debe
haber dos niños más altos que él y si
esteban es el décimo segundo más alto
entonces debe de haber once niños más
altos que el once niños más altos que él
por lo tanto en este salón de clases
tenemos once niños más bajos que el once
niños más altos que él hay suman
veintidós más esteban son veintitrés en
total
voy a tener 23 alumnos 23 alumnos y
bueno date cuenta que este era un
problema de fijarnos en contar bien
porque es muy fácil decir que hay 25
alumnos pensando que hay 12 más bajos 12
más altos más el o cometer algún error
de conteo pero bueno tenemos 23 alumnos
y vamos a pasar el siguiente problema
que es el problema número 11 el problema
número 11 que dice lo siguiente
en la función de x que está dada por
esto dejamos escribirlo aquí gx es la
función a x cuadrada es una función
cuadrática más bm x
a y c son números negativos
y se son menores que 0 entonces lo que
me preguntan es cuál de las siguientes
gráficas representa la gráfica de la
función g así que para esto
déjenme hacer té por aquí un plano
cartesiano déjame agarrar aquí mi eje x
va a ser más o menos esté por aquí y voy
a dibujar aquí un eje y
va a ser más o menos por aquí y voy a
poner que este es el eje de las equis
este es el eje de las 10 y bueno lo
primero que quiero que te des cuenta es
qué va a pasar si nosotros decimos que x
vale 0 si x vale 0 entonces éste se va
éste se van y gtx cortaría en el punto c
pero como se es negativo entonces la
función de x va a cortar por aquí en
algún valor negativo en el eje de las 10
porque se es negativo y es en el punto
en donde va a cortar en función g de x
entonces por aquí va a pasar eso en una
primera instancia ahora
por otra parte podremos darnos cuenta
que esta gráfica es simétrica bajo el
eje de las yes porque
por qué
no bueno no es simétrica bajo el eje de
las 10 o no forzosamente simétrica bajo
el eje detalles así que
no olvida lo que dije mejor voy a
utilizar que es negativa como a es
negativa a ver recordemos un poco si
tengo en la función game es igual a
equis cuadrada como se ve la gráfica de
esto pues tengo dos ejes un eje por aquí
un eje por acá y tendría una función
cuadrática que abre hacia arriba tendría
una función cuadrática que abre más o
menos así ahora si yo tengo jr es igual
a menos x cuadrada y esto lo hemos visto
varias veces en algunos vídeos sería muy
bueno que lo recordarás tendríamos la
gráfica de una función que se ve más o
menos así vamos a tener una función pero
ahora su cualidad es que abre hacia
abajo tengo una palabra que abre hacia
abajo
va a abrir hacia abajo más o menos así
es decir que cuando tenemos el
coeficiente al lado de la equis cuadrada
negativo tenemos una palabra que abre
hacia abajo entonces regresando a este
caso como es negativo debo de tener una
parábola que abra hacia abajo así que
voy a intentar dibujarla por aquí puedo
tener una parábola parecida a ésta va
por aquí va por aquí llega a este punto
y empieza a bajar abre hacia abajo esta
sería mi respuesta correcta esta sería
la gráfica de g
ahora no solamente podría ser así como
no sé exactamente bien los valores de x
cuadrada debe x ni dsm depende del valor
debe x también se podría ver la
siguiente manera podría verse más o
menos así que corte al eje de las 10 en
un valor negativo es decir que corte el
eje era 10 justo aquí pero no
forzosamente que sea simétrica abajo el
eje 10 se podría ver también algo así
que suba por aquí pasa por acá llega un
punto más alto y después empieza a bajar
y se vaya todo así
ésta también es una posible forma de la
gráfica de la función de x sin embargo
date cuenta que aquí hay dos cosas muy
importantes la primera es que debe de
cortar a elegir las 10 en un valor
negativo y la segunda es que debe de ser
una palabra es decir la gráfica de una
función cuadrática que abra hacia abajo
en como este caso o como este caso y si
te das cuenta todos los incisos que
tengo abre hacia arriba o cortan al eje
de las 10 en un valor positivo excepto
el inciso a el inciso a cumple estas dos
propiedades por lo tanto mis respuestas
el éxito am que es muy parecida a esta
gráfica solamente que tenemos una
gráfica de color azul y ya está
tenemos una parábola que abre hacia
abajo así que vamos a hacer el siguiente
ejercicio el problema número 12 déjenme
borrar esta pantalla y déjenme poner
aquí el problema número 2 el problema
número 12 tiene una figura muy parecida
a ésta así que déjame hacerla voy a
tener un rectángulo por aquí
y bueno cada uno de los vértices tiene
nombre este se llama b
este se llama a ave este se llama
y este se llama ver y después tengo tres
puntos tengo por aquí un punto p tengo
por aquí un punto uno y tengo por acá un
punto r y esto se ve bastante
interesante tengo una figura más o menos
así está a escala tengo estos tres
puntos pvr y me llama mucho la atención
vamos a ver qué dice el problema dice en
la figura siguiente dos puntos p q r
existen en una línea recta que es
paralela a la recta ave que es paralela
a la recta a d
si además sabemos que el valor de bs es
4 y el valor de ave es 6
este valor es 6
y estos tres puntos están en una línea
recta paralela a la recta de déjame
ponerlo por aquí tengo una recta
paralela a la recta de más o menos me
queda esta perfecto
así que pongamos una flecha por aquí
para decir que son paralelas estas dos
son paralelas y además me dicen que el
punto p y el punto q son simétricos bajo
la línea ave son simétricos bajo la
línea ave eso quiere decir que x distan
de la línea ave o dicho de otra manera
que esta distancia de aquí esta
distancia de aquí es la misma que esta
distancia de clint que esta distancia de
aquí estas dos distancias son iguales
porque la línea ave refleja los puntos p
y q de una manera simétrica y por otra
parte nos dicen que los puntos q y r son
simétricos bajo la línea setem
dicho de otra manera estos dos puntos
equidistantes
cdm podemos pensarlo como que esta
distancia esta de aquí y ya está esta
distancia es exactamente la misma x
distan de la recta 7 y entonces lo que
me preguntan es cuánto vale p r cuál es
la distancia de p r y bueno para sacar
pr wire esta fascinante el problema está
increíble porque fíjate bien si yo a
esta distancia de aquí hasta acá le
pongo el nombre de x entonces date
cuenta que esta distancia también tiene
el nombre de x como es la misma entonces
la distancia que hay de aquí acá es la
misma que la distancia que hay de aquí
acá que se llama x si por otra parte yo
le pongo a esta distancia el nombre de
james entonces la distancia de aquí a
camps es james y la distancia de aquí
acá también va a ser bien porque es la
misma son x
y ahora quiero que te des cuenta de lo
siguiente
cuánto vale x + ya esto le sumó bien
cuánto me da de sumar x + bueno pues yo
sé que x + gem es exactamente lo mismo
que toda esta distancia que tengo aquí
de aquí hasta que toda esta distancia es
de x + james pero yo sé que como es un
rectángulo toda esta distancia vale 4
por lo tanto x + es igual a 4 que justo
es lo ancho de este rectángulo y cuánto
es dpr no pues dpr es x + x x + x
y esto se llama james más y más bien y
esto cuanto es bueno pues si te das
cuenta es lo que vamos a hacer es unir
estos dos estos dos la suma de estos me
da 4 y por otra parte tengo este más
este de aquí y la suma de este más este
también es 4 por lo tanto al final la
suma de todo esto que tengo aquí es lo
mismo que 4 + 4 lo cual es 8
la distancia de pr es igual a 8 unidades
que por cierto es el inciso b está de
lujo fíjate bien cómo es la distancia de
aquí hasta acá es 4 y es la suma de x +
bien entonces x + james está distancia
más esta distancia también tienen que
sumar 4 y 44 es igual a 8 y vamos a
resolver el siguiente problema el
problema número 13 creo que vamos
bastante bien en este vídeo y dice si el
precio
no ya tengo un poco tiempo y me pongo
muy nervioso cuando me falta poco tiempo
así que mejor voy a tratar el problema
13 en el siguiente vídeo nos vemos mejor
en el siguiente vídeo